Alexandre lucachenko de retour en
première ligne du conflit ukrainien
presque tous les jours nos gardes
frontières documents divertibles de
provocation à la frontière de l'État
entreprises par les pays voisins de
l'abandon de cadavres à l'envoi
intentionnel de drones à travers la
frontière vers le Belarus depuis du
crâne
toujours dans la matinée le chef de
l'État Belarus a estimé que la situation
avait échappé à tout contrôle en
référence à la rébellion avortée du
groupe Wagner ce week-end une amorce de
critique de Vladimir Poutine de la part
d'un homme qui a pourtant dossé
pleinement le costume de vassal de
Moscou depuis 2020 cette année la
lucachenko fait appel à son allié
historique pour mettre au pas un
mouvement de contestation inédit mais la
crise qui a placé la Russie au bord du
gouffre ce samedi semble avoir tout
changé le maître du Kremlin présente
lui-même Alexandre lucachenko comme le
médiateur ayant facilité une sortie de
crise je suis reconnaissant au président
du Belarus Alexandre gregoriez Vics
lucaschenko pour ses efforts et sa
contribution au règlement pacifique de
la situation selon le récit officiel
remis en doute par certains analystes
c'est bien le chef de l'État Belarus qui
a permis de faire rentrer yefghani
Prigogine dans le rang c'est lui qui a
persuadé le chef de la milice Wagner de
rebrousser chemin et devenir s'exiler en
Biélorussie d'après les sites de suivi
du trafic rien le jet privé de prigogi
n'aurait d'ailleurs atterri à Minsk dans
la matinée dans sa dernière prise de
parole celui-ci déclarait même
qu'Alexandre lucachenko lui aurait
proposé de poursuivre ses activités
depuis le territoire Belarus un invité
qui pourrait devenir encombrant mais qui
montrerait la capacité de lucachenko à
100 tendre avec l'ensemble des factions
du pouvoir russe depuis le début de
l'offensive en Ukraine la Biélorussie
est devenue l'une des plus importantes
base arrière des troupes russes il y a
un mois un accord entre les deux pays à
autoriser le transfert d'armes nucléaire
de la Russie vers la Biélorussie
et visiblement